[Musique]
alors bon soir la planète une image en
direct de montréal vous voyez comme le
ciel est bas le ciel volent bas mais
nous nous voulons ou à cette émission de
tam-tam canada toujours avec nos
collègues qui sont là chaque semaine il
ya des rotations dans le personnel il ya
tellement personnel qu'il faut bien
faire une rotation tout le monde veut
être ici au même moment c'est pas
possible
alors cette semaine paloma martinez
bonjour marie claude simard bonjour
bonjour est alléchante à de chant des
marais remplacer quelqu'un à la dernière
minute qui refuse la partie sud secouée
bonjour la détention mais une chance que
ce vendredi pour vider les choses comme
les accès vous connaissez la tradition
vous n'avez aucune idée du sujet vous
arrivez avec votre bagage de
connaissances générales va falloir
spécialisés les choses ça pourrait aller
mieux
oui alors vous allez déjà l'émission
pour prouver vous avez des connaissances
et puis on reste positif aujourd'hui oui
alors on regarde cette vidéo 5 images ou
devenir le sujet des missions les gens à
la maison au bureau ou dans les avions
et 737 vous pouvez jouer également avec
nous si vous vous à ne plus le faire
bosser dur comme fer
oui alors cédé valley c'est un voyage à
l'est d'amiens bay n'ont pas d'avions
cette somme à passau pas délégué sa ces
cours me joindre à ces bosses en cours
au plus que c'est mignon c'est des
années 1960
màj aulas
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est l'internet les médias sociaux vous
écouter vous avez tous raison cette
semaine voici la réponse les émoticônes
pourriez vous sous forme d' émoticons
nous raconter votre vie faites le
maintenant seulement c'est le test
aujourd'hui
alors on va se poser la question est ce
que c'est c'est en train de devenir une
langue internationale entre le japonais
et l'espagnol et le canadien sk
possibilité de communiquer maintenant
vous savez à travers ce langage
universel avec louis ce qu'on peut faire
des français c'est trop uniformisé c'est
comme passer personnel parce que dire je
t'aime tellement façon de le dire mais
je dis seulement avec un quart houleux
gaston jones perd encore quand je me dis
que ça jeux spécifiques
c'est vrai il y en a toujours des
nouveaux à chaque année on annonce la
création de nouveaux émoticônes etc
c'est par période
il y en a qui fonctionne bien drapés
dans des pays où les petits kaka ça
fonctionne bien au canada mais pas mais
y'avait on peut mettre la couleur de
notre peau aussi on peut choisir la
couleur de la peau delaware du petit
bonhomme
elle vous prêt à gagner des points en
bois panneaux n'ont pas perdre cette
semaine premier jeu outre les baronnies
vannes on veut bien gagne combien de
boulin ne pas perdre ça c'est sympa mais
ça ça il ya trois jeux là pour le
premier jeu ou pas interpelle mais
soyons positifs pour un concert privé
c'est positif aujourd'hui alors voici
premier tour de la grosse boule
quel est selon vous l'émoticône le plus
utilisé au canada 1
il y en a beaucoup dans le monde qui est
fou très basse et vous avez un choix de
réponse je me gare même guidé les choses
interdit aux - jeu qu'on reste positif
le petit visage qui pleure de rire ses
skis et populeux peloton
mort de rire ok ça c'est votre
interprétation le b le petit visage avec
simple et beau sourire franc ou est ce
que c'est c'est le petit coeur tout
rouge tout simple qu'est-ce qui est le
plus populaire en ce moment je le sais
moi à moi je dirais b alors à dcl là là
le petit car tout simple alors je
m'assieds animaux de seconde qui dit abc
s'est passé 25 août et aujourd'hui on va
regarder la réponse c'est notre vidéo
numéro 2 réponse à la question d'un gros
ce but they were vous avez pas mal tous
raison et que vous allez pas mal tous
garder vos points aujourd'hui plutôt
rassurant on a une petite lunette un
petit coeur du petit karoo jetant ses
impressions selon facebook
alors si vous allez vers d'autres par
exemple via une compagnie qui a vu qu'on
est là mais la baisse a cédé par la sas
et c d'après une autre entreprise qui
s'appellera et speed internet.com
touquet satie coeur rouge qui prime au
canada corp j'avais aussi médecin de jeu
ce car aujourd'hui c'est ouais mais je
sais pas ce que vous perdiez aucun
penchant suis donc vous avez tous gardez
vous on est prêt pour voir ce qu'en
pense le spécialiste de l'émission
surtout qu'ils les sémiologues comment
vous savez ça étudiait les signes il a
dit anton a avant d'aller en on sait ça
comme ça alors non seulement sémiologue
et spécialiste des signes mais
chercheurs en littérature terrain du
numérique et combiner tous faisaient
comme un multi-spécialiste son nom c'est
gabriel tremblay gaudette bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté de participer à
l'émission aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas
professeur encore mais vous êtes
vraiment un expert au canada dans ce
genre de questions des émoticônes unis
mode seconde 1 et mogi faut faire
attention
genre et pas toujours le même au jeu
après sa semaine sur les leçons que j'ai
appris cette semaine vous de votre côté
vous intéresser à dison jusqu'où ça va
les màj lui leur utilisation dans la
société aujourd'hui la signification
d'ailleurs tout ça c'est très large la
question à laquelle on en aimerait
éventuellement réponse
on n'est pas obligé d'y arriver dessus
mais est-ce que ça constitue les bisons
les débuts d'une nouvelle langue
internationale
on a lancé ça comme idée vous levez les
yeux alors oui ça va bien ce qu'est ce
que vous pensez de l'avancée des émaux j
depuis une vingtaine d'années maintenant
bon je dirais probablement que ça n'est
pas à proprement parler une langue on va
appeler ça un système idéogrammes atik
donc en fait c'est un mode de
communication qui repose sur des
symboles visuels mais qui n'est pas
aussi fort mais qui n'est pas formé donc
de lettres qui n'ont pas d'alphabet à
proprement parler et qui donc n'a pas la
même
il n'y a pas une espèce d'autorité qui
régit l'utilisation d'énergie comme il
peut en avoir encore des langages on a
le fisc québécois française on a des
dictionnaires qui vont clairement
établir des significations partagée de
termes les maudits ce qui m'intéresse
moi titre de seigneur que c'est qu'on
n'est pas prêt à voir en direct
l'apparition de nouvelles formes de
communication dont qui sera jamais
l'égal du langage mais qui se met en
place graduellement qui n'est pas un
effet de mode qui est beaucoup de plus
en plus utilisés parce que il est
disponible sur nos appareils numériques
soit mon clavier de téléphone
intelligent auquel on prête une certaine
efficacité qui va permettre d'exprimer
des émotions des états d'âme de manière
prétendument efficace est clair c'est
pas toujours le cas qui n'est pas aussi
universel qu'on prétend parce qu'il ya
des significations les significations
des emd emoji vont varier d'une culture
à l'autre d'un groupe à l'autre
également et dans certains contextes
communications privées ou publiques
donc c'est pas si simple de dire que
parce que tout le monde a accès à des
hémorragies sur son téléphone et qu'il
n'y a pas de
lang comme des directions dans nos pays
comme la france en anglais qu on peut
communiquer avec n'importe qui sont
entraînantes en soit démolie et la com
quel sort va être limpide
donc c'est pour mettre des morts en dix
ans je pense pas que ça va vraiment
devenir un nouveau langage mais ça fait
partie des modes de communication
actuels et ses façons de voir s'élargir
d'année en année comme l'avait mentionné
des nouveaux symboles qui sont ajoutés
on essaie de de plus en plus inclusif
qu'on peut avoir par exemple des couples
auteurs homosexuels qu'hétérosexuels des
couples de différentes une grande
diversité ethnique maintenant qui est
permise par les lésés moggi on inclut de
plus en plus dans les derniers ajouts y
avait des handicapés donc des sabots
pour les handicapés des symboles pour
les menstruations
donc on veut inclure et pouvoir
représenter plus en plus de réalité pâle
l'entremise de ses symboles avec
lesquels on est disons que prix
maintenant alice ben jusque là le monde
de la littérature est habitué à la
recherche je suis la sémiologie ou sur
la sémiotique textuel donc en tant que
chercheurs dans ce domaine là est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire une espèce de
bilan quel est le point le point de la
situation en ce qui concerne la place du
langage des signes
dans la littérature contemporaine
j'aurai besoin et généralement on a
besoin de 45 heures pour mettre au
complet j'aurais pas tout ce temps là
devant moi
en fait non c'est ça pose des questions
vraiment intéressant parce que justement
les il ya quelque chose de vivant dans
le langage aussi bien les mots qu'on
utilise convoi antique tonnerre ils sont
pas utilisés seulement dans cette
conclure leur aussi bien les est maudit
par leur utilisation leur sens va être
modifié
donc on sait par exemple que c'est assez
clair sont en voir un bonhomme soraya
bien qu'on veut lui signifier qu'on est
heureux mais il ya certains fruits et
légumes quand les gens voient qu'on est
parti un parent d épicerie vous voyez ce
que je veux dire la berge n ya une
connotation qui est quand même assez
précise ça désigne un organe sexuel par
exemple et
donc ça on voit justement un quart des
nouveaux émoticons mais celui où on veut
montrer quelque chose de petite taille
d'après moi ça reste est aussi utile
dans un contexte sexuel
sa pose et qu'elles sont assez
intéressants sur le plan légal parce que
encore une fois comme on a pas de
consensus sur comment ces terminaux sont
doivent être compris ou utilisé dans les
cas par exemple de harcèlement sexuel
on peut plaider l'innocence en allégeant
voyez on est maudit de clin d'oeil à
quelqu'un mais c'était seulement pour
vour avoir l'air sympathique complice
alors que ça peut aussi être utilisé
pour draguer donc c'est vraiment peau ce
qui est fascinant c'est vraiment
commencé en train de se produire devant
nous en direct et qu'on sait pas encore
qu'est ce que ça va donner parlement
puis ensuite marie claude géré une
question a fait comment on peut évaluer
l'efficacité des de la communication à
travers les énergies est ce qu'on peut
dire qu il y a plus ou moins des
malentendus entre les personnes qui
communiquent à travers ces mots gila en
fait ça aussi il n'y a pas de réponse
unique dans la mesure où les mondes du
camp s'est combiné avec du texte écrit
ça peut permettre justement de lever des
ambiguïtés
je donne un exemple imaginer une
situation où quelqu'un vous annoncerai
je suis ton artiste préféré ton concert
ce soir j'ai acheté des billets est ce
que tu venais lots pour une raison x ne
pouvait pas que vous avez d'autres
engagements si vous répondre dans la
personne merci d'avoir averti radar
secondes
c'est un message qui peut être compris
plusieurs manières parce que ça peut
être comme si on met si on dit merci
d'avoir invertir dans la seconde avec
une hémorragie de clin d'oeil
cela dit je te taquine taurin douter
cette enquête et et oppressant
organisation mais si on met en mots
justes avec quelqu'un franchit lonza la
personne que le c'était un peu du
sarcasme marché qui n'en ai pas parlé
avant parce que j'avais vraiment voulu
voir ce concerne donc généralement les
est maudit peuvent permettre de préciser
le ton d'un message
on va pouvoir identifier clairement si
c'est 10 de manière affectueuse ou
amoureuse par exemple mais le problème
qu'on peut avoir c'est quand les gens
commencent à utiliser que des mondes y
ait là je vais vous avouer quelque chose
même ce phénomène
m'intéresse dans le monde je vais pas
bien terne qui s'appelle story au
gangster c'est à dire c'est les rappeurs
qui vont parler de criminalité alors que
eux mêmes ne sont pas des criminels
donc sondés sont des crimes mais
seulement studio moi je suis un peu un
espèce de studio leinster est maudit
parce que j'en emploi assez peu dans la
communication
je suis un peu de la vieille école comme
ça j'ai écrit les phrases complètes je
m'aime toujours mettre les accents au
bon endroit quand j'envoie des messages
donc l'efficacité qui promet limongi moi
disons que je n'emploie pas et c'est de
plus en plus fréquent que les gens se
parlent carrément ou s'envoie des
messages rapides dans les moules j ai
comme moi je suis pas certaine la
signification à chaque fois des fois
j'en reçois et là je dois dire la
personne je sais que tu m'as envoyé à
mbuji pour être rapide mais j'aurai
besoin que tu m'expliques qu'est ce que
tu me disais exactement compte tenu de
ce contexte
dans ce cas là on peut pas parler
vraiment d'efficacité la question que
jésus pensez vous pas que c'est un peu
réducteur de croire qu'on puisse
vraiment exprimer des émotions avec des
petits symboles aussi simpliste hic que
ça quand on pense que de tous les temps
le lait les poètes ou peu importe des
personnes dans la vie réelle expression
d'imposition est tellement complexe que
c'est un peu réducteur justement de la
question de l'efficacité que ce sens et
permettent
louise est effectivement on pourra dire
que ça ne permettra pas les nuances que
le langage écrit pourrait permettre on
s'imaginerait mal proposé de la poésie
on est maudit pour le moment encore une
fois je pense que c'était beaucoup plus
difficile d'envisager quelques années
parce que le vocabulaire pas le
vocabulaire mail le bassin des mauges
disponibles n'étaient pas assez grands
pour vraiment permettre une grande
diversité d'expression il ya d'abord un
projet qui est assez assez amusant et
plus dont une oeuvre conceptuelle qu'un
livre convenir au complet qui s'appelle
emoji dick ou en fait un créateur à
utiliser le service amazon torque pour
demander à des utilisateurs le prix moby
dick de melville il ya séparées dont
phrase par phrase et il a soumis à ses
utilisateurs le défi de exprimer cette
france là grâce à des modes j'ai ensuite
faisait valider la france l'état pur
c'est par d'autres utilisateurs et ainsi
il a voulu reproduire moby des pères des
maudits évidemment quand on prend le
livre qu'on essaie donné au complet on
se rend compte que c'est très difficile
de vraiment comprendre même ce qui se
passe ça n'a pas la puissance la
puissance là vers la beauté de l'oeuvre
de melville mais en même temps moi je
peux je dis peut-être qu'en ce moment
non on peut mal imaginer comment on
pourrait avoir une expressivité forte
avec les mots les images mais comme
c'est assez récent et que c'est un
langage que des gens vont s'approprier
je pense qu'on peut avoir des résultats
qui montrent époque autour des
chefs-d'oeuvre mais qui pourrait du
moins nous étonner j'aurai une autre
question concernant les la place qui
joue les énergies ce qui concerne la
ponctuation parfois j'ai l'impression
quand je lis des messages des plus
jeunes personnes que moi que c'est comme
si les mots j'y venais remplacer le
poing levé la virgule
parce que des fois ils font des phrases
comme saint pompon actuation aucune et
puis ça fait en sorte qu'ils mettent des
màj entre les entre les mots donc je me
dis est ce que ça joue vraiment un rôle
de remplaçant est ce que ça remplace
vraiment la ponctuation parfois les
énergies avant qu'il réponde parlement
jallet embrayé suis votre question est
ce que les émaux chine représente
traitement une menace pour la langue
surtout pour les jeunes qui sont en
perte de repères en ce qui concerne la
correction
bon donc ouais deux questions très
intéressante pour ce qui est la première
de la ponctuation disons que moi pour
sentir que je peux vraiment me prononcer
là-dessus faudrait que maman je fasse
une étude de corpus donc par exemple que
je croise un groupe de jeunes que je
regarde et me voir s'il ya des usages
leur emploi des mots diversité des
usages systématique
je pense que avec les gens avec qui je
communique personnellement je vois comme
ceux qui en utilisent beaucoup ça crée
une espèce d'effet de retenue et même
que visuellement justement qu'on soit
message ça ponctuent la lecture du
message parce qu'il ya des est modique
apparaissent donc ses employés encore
une fois dans ce cas là en complément
c'est une forme ou ci est là pour
répondre aux questions à ce que sam en
péril la langue
elle se serait pas disons la première
fois qu'on croit le langage menacée par
l'apparition de nouvelles technologies
ou de nouvelles possibilités de
s'exprimer
ce qui est intéressant selon moi ce que
à une époque les magistrats en plus une
affaire de jeunes et les jeunes ont
souvent tendance à s'approprier du
langage à se créer leurs propres codes
d'expression donc moi je vais travailler
mon âge mais disons quand j'étais jeune
l'éditeur en anglais comme co ou ratent
les de l'emploi utilisé pour décrire
quelque chose demeure positive je
connais pas quels sont les expressions
des jeunes en ce moment mais
généralement cette volonté lot de se
créer un espèce de propre langage pour
un groupe social ou une génération c'est
une manière de dire je veux pas exprimer
la même manière car mes parents je veux
avoir ma propre fondane engage donc pour
les jeunes employés beaucoup plus des
moujiks à leurs parents c'est une
manière de signifier pour eux leurs
différences dans leur forme de
communication c'est sûr que si on n'est
plus beaucoup plus des maudits et qu'on
perd le réflexe de faire des phrases
complètes
ça va peut-être parce qu'on va prendre
des mauvais pied qu'on va plus être
capable d'écrire des phrases ou non
peut-être aussi que utiliser beaucoup
les médias sociaux peut nous amener à ça
si on est toujours sur twitter etc on
veut écrire des phrases très romancé à
l'époque où la netteté de 140 caractères
si on met des images sur instagram et
qu'on veut avoir des commentaires
rapides ça peut revendre ça m'a entraîné
une forte la dégradation de la maîtrise
du langage mais en même temps les
longues sais pas si et elle évolue
l'élan et je pense que employés lésés
moggi pourrait devenir une manière de
danse dans sa communication écrite par
des combinaisons en textes et images qui
d'après moi peut enrichir le langage et
non pas en constitue une perte
gabriel on a une dernière question il
reste 40 secondes dans le fond pour
simplifier un peu le décryptage de ces
six là est ce qu'il ne serait pas
intéressant de créer un dictionnaire des
est maudit il ya justement quelque chose
qui s'appelle et mode super dur qui est
donc un équivalent de
wikipedia sur laquelle on peut se rendre
et l'autre donc on a des formes de
définition ce qui permet aussi de lever
les ambiguïtés sur une situation
culturelle on en mentionnant début
d'émission à ce que ça peut donner en
langage universel j'en exemple très
rapide les maudit où on a quelqu'un leur
marché et de l'acsor des narines en
occident on va interpréter cela comme de
la colère mais au japon dans les ordres
des cyniques ce soit des mangas ou
l'animé c'est avoir exprimé une forme de
triomphe
donc quand on lit des modèles pour des
doutes on peut se rendre sur les maux du
pays des banques est maintenant dans un
contexte ça peut vouloir dire certaines
choses donc il ya une espèce de
dictionnaires 8 km en classe par les six
autres années alors imagine médias vous
allez voir ça peut-être que durant les
prochaines minutes on pourra nous même
aller sur le web on est capable quand
même on y reste deux doigts et gabriel
merci beaucoup d'avoir apporté sa
l'émission vos connaissances et puis je
vois qu'on est vraiment dans un domaine
où il ya beaucoup de recherches à faire
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de dessous a
demandé où en avant pour voir comment la
jeunesse notamment mais tu dis il n'y a
pas mal tenus là je vous parlera des
magies mais je pense qu'on n'aurait pas
la même pas alors mais je veux quand
même je vous signale mon coeur qui boira
comme ça vous remercier des coupes c'est
moi qui vous remercie c'était
désagréable c'est à gabrielle tremblay
gaudette qui est signe aux log
oui les chercheurs en littérature
numérique et sémiologue il fait de la
sémiologie d'études des signes par les
textes voir jon leyne une mémoire
ils criaient on y va pour le deuxième
jour
je sais vous devez tous garder votre en
boule pour le 2 avril d'accord je pas
perdant gens jugent que des gannes ça
serait trop l'a fait légion coa les
mauges immédiat et puis je fais bien
qu'on dit la taxe ça vient du japon que
l'origine des émaux jc le japon en parle
aussi d'une émoticons des émoticons de
féminin je rappelle la leçon j'ai appris
cela de moi même parce que fut que je
fasse beaucoup et très attention pour me
rappeler c'est pas là au nom et moi j
pediatr et mange ipdia pas médias comme
un dictionnaire universel
alors pendant qu'on regarde ça pendant
qu'on s'instruit voici la question
màj est un terme issu du japonais pour
décrire ses seins bonne inspiration
initialement donc que japonaises qui
sont répandues dans le monde entier
depuis 20 ans dites moi que signifie
véritablement emoji à attention c'est
pas évident est ce que ca
le mot màj signifie émotion le coeur qui
bat est ce que le p le mot màj signifie
image un peu ennuyant ça comme réponse
est ce que c'est c'est le mot et magie
signifie mini symbole et mogi en orge a
pas d émotion l'accord qui bat le coeur
qui bat donc ce serait l'émotion à moi
sinon très bien en fait c'est
l'utilisation d'un symbole bpt ont
manifesté quelque chose qui vient de
l'intérieur
ok c'est bien j'aime beaucoup la réponse
images ça veut dire images seulement au
départ peut-être que ce mot-là a été
employé pour que dit que c'est devenu
après des excuses des moyens
d'expression d'émotion qui peuvent être
une signification ou une émotion une
émotion qui régénère pas l'image d'accor
est ce quelqu'un il répond c'est le mot
màj signifie mini symbole
d'accord je vais les autres conservent
leurs boules parce que ya en fait c'est
un jeu de mots qui contient à la fois
l'idée d'image est à la fois l'idée
d'émotion image en japonais et moggi
pour imaginer mention encore dans
l'étymologie et moi je ne suis pas juge
pas très bon voilà la dernière voit
rarement traduits des jantes à poney on
n'a pas le temps
j'aimerais vous présenter quelque chose
d'amusant
c'est sur la page de tan tan canada pas
en ce moment même alors que nous
diffusions en direct mais dans à peine
30 minutes lorsque nous allons orient
bobines et les missions et la mettre sur
internet pour être vu pour plusieurs
générations à venir
il ya la page de tan tan canada qui
accueille donc cette vidéo de youtube de
facebook etc et on va regarder la vidéo
niro 5
vous allez voir on a déposé à des images
y non ça aurait été trop facile
c'est pas notre fonction comme comme
animateur is that her on a déposé dans
des références à des reportages qu'on a
fait dans le passé sur cette question la
brûlante actualité vidéo numéro 5
ce conte la wii alors vous voyez cncd
nouvelle présentation visuelle
ce qui nous vaut se met alors à la page
c'est la page de timbres avec l'émission
de la semaine dernière ont fait vous
pouvez écouter oui je vais vous montrer
comment c'est facile
ah oui à cette pâle aime la bonne vidéo
alors oui on sait pas la bonne vidéo
mais c'est un exemple
oui et a pas d'accord donc là ça pour
vos fêtes sans joie vous regardez
l'émission d'aujourd'hui
oui je sais que c'est pas facile
techniquement pour vous de vous porter
un futur comme ça mais faire ensemble
oui très bien alors on remet ça de côté
là on va dessin c'est un bar de notre
vidéo où notre bande sonore
[Musique]
oui le quatrième votre attention ce
quatrième d'opinion et d'émotion le
canada salue la whey les canadiens qui
sont les plus friands aux utilisateurs
de certains votes squibb irene ayala on
a beaucoup de classe
là vous avez des informations sur les
américains ce qui sommes sales et les
fusils ou pas comparé aux autres nations
on va se comparer aux autres très bons
une émission internationales comme la
banque a pâti des loups vous dès 12h30
déjeuner du petit déjeuner alors non ce
n'était pas méchant de ma personne alors
si ce sera notre prochaine vidéo et
c'est un jeune devrait on parler des
jeunes partent aux lèvres avoir leur
place à cette émission un peu plus que
oui alors un automate bourges connaissez
ma dufour peut-être que vos enfants
connaissent le mot du jour
il travaille travaille sur pour le pet
il travaillera du canada et il produit
des six que c'est moi c'est pas grave le
temps je capitule à cette émission
il a fait un reportage aux savants sur
ce qu'ils voudraient voir les émaux j'y
pense que les adultes n'ont pas tout
inventé voici ce que me propose encore
une fois thomas dufour de zone jeunesse
à radio canada on le regarde ça dure par
raymond d'acier fou le nombre des
matches comme qui existe en ce moment
est au regard de celle on pense qu'un
dessin pour exprimer chaque chose qu'on
veut c'est lol c'est triste je viens
petit et le classique
j'ai oublié ma crème solaire mais malgré
les centaines de milliers d mode seconde
qui existe je trouve qu il nous en
manque encore quelques uns qui serait
pratiqué qu'ils ouvraient en chaîne des
cinq des situations qu'ils arrivent
régulièrement
premier exemple qui est selon moi un
incontournable
désolé gains je pourrais pas y aller je
suis pris dans le ventre d'une belle
jeune et des fiestas fraude
non je n'ai pas une émeute secondes pour
décrire ce serait bon plus et bien pour
tous ceux à qui ça arrive souvent que
moi voici les mots du conte désolé j'ai
pris dans une baleine y en a plein comme
ce qui serait super utile du genre tu le
crois au repos mais nouveau directeur
d'école d'un cactus ou encore bizarre je
me suis arrêté par la police et la jambe
et une oreille un peu démesuré
évidemment je suis pas pratique pour moi
ça serait salut tout le monde
merci d'avoir été là même à capter
définitif à diraz avec des idées très
jolie faudrait peut-être le sait la
boule rouler longtemps
comment voulez vous on entre alors je
crois vous avez perdu trois points c'est
juste parce que je vous ai suivi du
[Rires]
troisième jeu on vient un peu la notion
de fabriquer des idées des phrases
d'accord vous allez voir ce que vous
allez non je vous poste de ddc trouvait
trop facile alors voici je vous propose
la vidéo du héros c'est vous regardez
avec moi pendant qu'on regarde on se
parle
oui la première personne qui va pouvoir
me dire qu'elle la phrase représentés
par des trois petites images qui vont
apparaître dans quelques instants
la phrase oui il faut créer une phrase
ça fait quelque chose
oui sa percée de la vidéo oui la
première personne qui me répondent
correctement ne perd par 5 50 boul
les autres vous perdez je m'attendais à
quelque chose du genre
ça s'en vient s'asseoir et vous prêts ça
s'en vient trois petites images trop
petit notre compte que c'est qu'on fasse
pas faire du bruit parce qu'ils adorent
ça pourrait être ça mais c'est pas ça
c'est un film au silence des agneaux oui
alors qu'on sait 1.5 en goule mais un
deuxième vieux qui s'en viennent de là
on vous donne la réponse on est très on
le pensait que ça prendrait plus de
temps alors le silence des agneaux la
régie vous a devancé apparemment alors
voilà un autre film sans lien on
continue à regarder la vidéo parce qu'il
ya un autre nos trois images qui va vous
proposer un autre type de film et là des
films vous pouvez y jouer
berglof les deux autres qu'est ce que
c'est le site du film rencontre ou pas
toutefois si ces plus récents ça oh je
suis pas bonne la barbe au monde est
restée silencieuse
le film contact
ces contacts n'ont rencontré troisième
type c 1966 avait dès à présent temps de
rémanence est moins bien qu'une soucoupe
martiaux et puis il ya une machine à
calculer
johnnie carson était la maîtresse dans
les deux films ok d'accord moi je vous
dis oui fallait boucler dans les
troquets bon bah ouais pas grave alors
nous avait perdu seulement 20 boules
vous êtes à 66 marie-claude et à sang et
vous êtes à 50 boules précipite en
troisième position et la régie technique
qui sont ces s'assure qu'ils ont
chamboulé
ouais exactement on arrête la boule on
joue à banjul n'y a rien à gagner mais
sauf que je pense que vous avez
s'amusant pas amusant je sais pas image
de la semaine il faut deviner c'est quoi
ce s'est passé dans le monde cette
semaine ça c'est pas passé au canada
belt musique de tant de tension et je
répond par oui ou par non quelle est
notre image à commencer par les
continents parce que ça va peut-être
vous aider c'est pas ça non en asie non
on a une chute dont il reste plus
beaucoup de considérables oui les pays
aux pays bas bon ok c'est faisons au sud
plus au sud c'est pas les gilets jaunes
c'est plus au sud encore un peu plus à
l'ouest au portugal non de plus à
l'ouest
hadj salah fait plus à l'aise a mis
l'italie
ouais voilà italie il n'y a pas eu un
incident qui a bientôt là il n'a pas non
la démission s'est pendu c'est pas ça de
barbara bien tourné c'est une histoire
qui a bien tourné qui aurait fait mal
une histoire d'autobus je vous aime
l'histoire d'autobus en italie des
enfants 50
je veux toi les nouvelles parce que
c'était à cbc news
c'était un accident c'était ben s'est
toujours montré les images d'un corps
alors ça se passe en italie je pense
c'est mercredi et il ya un conducteur
d'origine sénégalaise qui a pris en
otage 50 enfants et je pense couple z et
voulait et voulait mettre le feu à
l'autobus et les enfants sont parvenus à
sortir alors que les policiers
on coince et l'autobus pour pas qu'ils
aillent plus loin alors que ça s'est
bien terminé mais la l'autobus a pris
feu voici les enfants qui s'en s'ont
réchappé en sortant vers l'arrière et ce
sénégalais voulait attirer l'attention
sur le sort des personnes qui arrivent
d'afrique du nord et qui meurent noyés
dans la merde parce que votre message
pour n'était pas voir les mains à la
bonne bon mais ça avec 40,1 jojo on
donne pas le nom mais je pense une belle
tradition maintenant on donne pas son
jeu qu'on prince son désespoir
probablement parce que c'est vrai que le
destin de ces gens là c'est souvent
tragiques
donc non maman pour sa part s'en est
prise d'otages mais j'ai pas suivi le
dénouement est laquelle elle savait que
notre invité du sémiologue même s'il n'a
pas gagné les points aux mondieux
sélection de joueurs trempe de jouer les
gens les uns contre les autres ce sont
des concurrents par le on le disait en
coulisses dans tout le monde du livre un
peu totalement à folie avec cette
attaque perpétrée à l'oratoire saint
joseph c'est là que tu casses
malheureusement l'état du prêtre abl
c'est le cycle 2 go donc elle pourrit
qui officie alors à toi depuis environ
20 ans
paname et transporté à l'hôpital
quand on est entré en studio on ne
savait pas on ne savait pas parce que le
principal suspect a été arrêté pour moi
sera entendu cet après-midi et
probablement il va comparaître
justement la force des émotions motivé
le mal comme le bien ça montre comment
les émoticônes seront jamais capables de
34 ans m c'est à ce sujet mais je pense
que vraiment ce langage là ça va
toujours demeurer spécial parce qu'en
réalité faux faite en présence de
quelqu'un je passais solange nous
contredire ouais j'ai reçu un courriel
sur mon téléphone portable de wal mart
ou algues vertes parce que je suis
abonné à l'heure des clients à savoir ce
qui est quel genre de chose il n'a pas
pris comme ça je gaspille monoplace
comme du board et je regarde ses marques
et voici nos domaines stephen puis un
niveau de ce code avec un beau sourire
jaune d'armand sur mon téléphone j'ai
dit bon tu seras pas d'ailleurs ça vient
de rentrer dans mon là ça y est c'est
dans le commerce
je pense que beaucoup de manipulations
possibles avec les émoticônes de nous
mêmes on en fait un peu c'est on va dire
quelque chose un petit peu corsé à
quelqu'un mais pour être sûr que qu'elle
prenne bien on va mettre un sourire puis
on va manipuler un peu le nom mais c'est
bien d'avoir ces tentatives ne sait
jamais si c'est une façon rationnelle de
partir de l'émotion c'est comme ça ma
choquer j'en ai besoin de temps semaine
ou quoi non mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
avoir à obtenir de l'autre on pourrait
avoir comme enfin une tentative de
manipulation des masses que je dis c'est
que c'est normal quand on écrit un
message on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir
transmettre la même chose qu'on transmet
en personne mais c'est normal qu'on
essaie de trouver des manières de
transmet notre émotion à travers l'écrit
ou à travers les points chauds
sympa que la meilleure façon de
transmettre n'est vraiment émotion
réelle à quelqu un certain on peut pas
toujours mais souvent on veut notamment
pas nécessairement voir quelqu'un votent
pas nécessairement la plus bizarre que
je vais le texte et j'en ai envoyé un
petit palais que ça on n'a pas le choix
que des communiqués de ce serait pour la
docteure n'a pas le choix mais chacun
d'eux n'a pas chaud ça simplifie je ne
sais pas s'il doit tous malheureusement
le compte beaucoup
on est dans le contexte des nouvelles
technologies où les choses vont
tellement vite qu'on à la maison j'ai
toujours beaucoup aimé mais je me rends
compte que ça fasse la bise et ça
facilite un peu le dire je t'aime à
quelqu'un qui me préoccupe moi c'est la
même veine d un mode coop à ce que
j'entends ici et quand je suis sur
messenger avec les copains pour dire bon
ça bien été aujourd'hui non c'est un
gros signal de pétards jeu pas bon j'ai
appelé cette semaine qu une courge c'est
un signal c'est bon c'est la même veine
c'est dans les messages gmail par
exemple il ya quand le patron envoie un
message très bien aujourd'hui jeudi 7
j'ai le choix
merci beaucoup aux mais bon comme
d'habitude du méga dépend donc sa femme
j'aime pas beaucoup ça j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça au début mais là je me dis
pourquoi je reçois du patron oui ok je
me dis est-ce qui s'est donné la peine
de vraiment été chercher mon courrier je
t'encourage pas de jours le patron
ces réseaux sont coupables également et
avant de partir on a notre application
de radio canada international qui permet
de nous écouter en tout temps dans
toutes les langues dans lesquelles nous
chaque semaine nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne je pense que l'image parle
d'elle même pas ce que vous voyez ça
c'est un téléphone et on peut voir que
c'est la question paraît en cinq ans
différentes l'une étant français je
crois
voilà donc un joaillier comme c'est bon
ça paraît bien l'image sur la télé face
à sa honte en anglais non on va voir un
extrait de l'émission de link voilà
c'est nous
et puis donc ça c'est le menu de toutes
sortes de choses évidemment toutes les
catégories mais aussi à des quizz bas ok
voilà la meilleure façon de s'informer
sur le canada pourrait ça pour avoir
cette application et si vous avez un
téléphone android ça va être
[Musique]
je vois que lille - l'application r6 et
joue aussi sur notre site web
sur la droite de toutes nos pages web
palpage ont compliqué là dessus en
principe pour qu'on soit dirigé vers le
bon endroit c'est ça oui je vous demande
parce que moi il faut il faudrait s'en
va téléphone aller sur notre site
allez cliquer sur l'icône de
l'application n'est pas manqué d'aller
directement à votre goût surtout ça je
sais très bien merci beaucoup pour être
venu cette semaine
ça a été très agréable de jouer avec les
images et puis le voir au fond c'est pas
encore une langue et on espère que ça
sera pas encore exactement ça s'ajoute à
nous c'est l'innovation du net unies
monsieur alléchante hadj adama la
semaine prochaine merci martin à la
semaine prochaine tout le monde
bye
on